angels will be there to welcome
them. Meaning, when they are
resurrected from their graves.
Saying to them, this is your
day that you all were promised.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala on
the day when we will roll up
the heavens Just a scribe
rolls up scrolls. Just as we
have began the first creation,
we will return it to such.
Meaning that, just as Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala initially
created the first creation, and
as he created the first
creation, he will reduce the
creation back to that
nothingness. Or what is
intended is that, just as he,
created the first creation, he
will recreate everything again
says Subhanahu wa ta'ala this
is a promise upon us that we
will do this that everyone will
pass away and will be
resurrected will be resurrected
and given life anew by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala then says
in the next verse and indeed we
have written in a Zabur
Some of the scholars mentioned
that this is the book of Dawood
Alaihi Salam. Others say,
what's meant here is the more
general meaning of a which
means that Allah has written in
every revelation that he has
sent to mankind.
fading that the earth will be
inherited
by my righteous servants. My
righteous servants shall
inherit the earth. And what's
meant by the earth here is
paradise. It is not the earth.
Rather it is the land. The
place. Earth will cease to be
on the day of resurrection. and
so shall inherit the earth is a
bit of a is a bit of
patient
translation. Rather what is
meant is paradise. It is
referred to as the land, the
home, the place. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that this place shall be shall
be inherited. a given
Hill, the righteous slaves of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. He
says, subhanahu wa ta'ala
Indeed, there is in this
efficient, that which is
sufficient for a people who
desire to worship Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This verse
means that this book, the Quran
what is in it of guidance to
Allah of direction, of
enlightenment, of wisdom, in
it,
enough and it is sufficient for
anyone who truly desires to be
an astute servants of Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Who anyone
for anyone who chooses and
desires to be.
close
faint of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and one who worships
Allah Meaning that this Quran,
this revelation of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. It has
enough in it for anyone to
become near to Allah.
Anything that we could ever
hope for. With regards to
nearness to Allah Subhanahu wa
ta'ala. This is sufficient
guidance for us. We don't need
to go into other books, to
other religions, to other
philosophies, etcetera. I know
that this is kind of
popular amongst people as being
open minded and being
cosmopolitan, and so forth.
However, this is in reality
playing with fire. And it will
confuse people. And this book,
the Quran is sufficient. It is
sufficient for a person who
wishes to gain nearness to
Allah. If a person wants
something else, well then,
maybe they have other things,
other intentions and that is a
different story. However, for
those who wish to worship Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, that is
truly their intention. This
book, the Quran, the Sunnah is
sufficient for them. says and
we have sent you not except as
a mercy
all of mankind. What's meant
here? By all of mankind, it
could be translated as well as
all of the creation is that by
his message, it is a mercy in
the sense that people are given
guidance after guidance was
almost obliterated from the
Earth. And now have a chance
and an opportunity to better
themselves, better their lives
and have an opportunity to
build a relationship with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and to gain
nearness to Allah. also to gain
admittance into paradise.
Allah They, commanding the
prophet it is merely sent as
revelation to me that your lord
is one lord. Meaning, the one
worthy of worship is Allah
alone. being that that is the
case? Are you all in submission
to this? Are you all in
submission? And what's meant
here by submission is a very
specific submission. Is
submission in the legislative
sense of submission And this is
a topic that we will discuss
tomorrow inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]